c'est lors du second débat de ce sens
public qui nous amène il nous ramène un
an en arrière quand le grand public
découvre ce nom chat GPT l'intelligence
artificielle devient accessible à tous
et va prendre en quelques mois une place
grandissante dans beaucoup d'entreprises
c'est un progrès pour l'humanité ou le
début de son déclin face aux machines
question vaste évidemment que l'on va
poser comment garder la main sur
l'intelligence artificielle quels
métiers sont les plus menacés avant de
répondre à ces questions Cécile Sixou
nous détail ces progrès là
impressionnant réalisés en seulement 12
mois navigation par GPS outil de
traduction diagnostics médicaux ou
encore assistants vocaux domestiques
depuis plusieurs années l'intelligence
artificielle est partout et souvent vous
l'utiliser au quotidien sans le savoir
mais il y a un an une révolution un
tsunami a fait son apparition dans ce
monde chat GPT ce robot conversationnel
fort de 100 millions d'utilisateurs
permet d'écrire des textes sur n'importe
quel sujet
ou de simuler des conversations humaines
et ce à partir de donn trouvé sur
internet un bouleversement de nos
habitudes dessine le Sénat
français en 2080 Laurent Alexandre
ancien médecin et auteur de livres sur
l'intelligence artificielle aime
s'amuser avec sa dernière version comme
toujours il imagine un futur très
technologique
et avec une adhésion de la totalité de
la population pour lui tout va trop vite
et il est alarmiste sur l'avenir cette
intelligence artificielle pourrait
dépasser l'intelligence humaine menacer
des milliers d'emploi et construire une
société à deux vitesses l'intelligence
artificielle galopeppe beaucoup plus
vite qu'on l'imaginait mais nous ne
sommes toujours pas
préparés la réflexion politique la
réflexion de l'école la réflexion de
l'hôpital sur la réorganisation de la
société à l'air de l'intelligence
artificielle est totalement
ambriillonnaire et on risque une crise
sociale parce qu'une partie importante
de la population risque d'être dépassé
et il faut trouver des solutions parce
qu'on ne peut pas imaginer une société à
plusieurs vitesses avec des des exclus
de l'intelligence artificielle mais au
contraire pour cette spécialiste de
l'intelligence artificielle dans le
monde de l'art il ne faut pas agiter les
peurs on peut demander ce qu'on veut av
bant Gog donc par exemple qui es-tu les
chatbots sont une opportunité à moins d'
y mettre des limites on est à un début
de champ des possibles où j'ai
l'impression qu'on n pas encore ouvert
toutes les tous les cas d'usage toutes
les mises en œuvre possibles de de
l'intelligence artificielle et en ça
c'est une période qui est assz
fascinante pour pour cette raisonl après
je pense que justement dès lors qu'on
est dans une phase de constitution d'un
écosystème et d'émergence c'est aussi le
moment de réfléchir tous ensemble
collectivement pour se dire en tant que
société en tant que citoyen de quelle
façon on estime que c'est désirable ou
non d'utiliser l'intelligence
artificielle limiter les dérives sans
pour autant enfrainer les sorts à
l'instar de l'Europe les pouvoirs public
dans le monde commence à plancher sur
des
législations l'humain sera-t-il dépassé
par l'intelligence artificielle qui a
créé comment maîtriser cette IA c'est le
thème de notre débat avec Christine
Lavarde bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
sénatrice LRD haute scène présidente de
la délégation à la prospective Olivier
lascar bonsoir et bienvenue récteur en
chef du pôle digital de Sciences et
Avenir la recherche et puis auteur de ce
livre enquête sur Elon Musk l'homme qui
défie la science qui est aux éditions
alisio alisiocience euh Jean-Gabriel
Gancia bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue heureux
de vous accueillir vous êtes professeur
d'informatique à la Sorbonne euh
chercheur au sein du laboratoire de
recherche en informatique de Sorbonne
université et puis vous avez présidé le
comité d'éthique du Centre national pour
la recherche scientifique pour le du
CNRS évidemment euh en France question
assez générale tiens pour commencer et
là on parle de chat GPT dans sa dernière
version la version 4 qui est quand même
beaucoup plus puissante que la
précédente Christine Lavarde est-ce que
vous êtes bluffé par cette dernière
génération de cette a générative c'est
terme qu'on alors complètement alors à
titre personnel moi je n'utilise pas
chat GPT ni dans les versions anciennes
ni dans les version moderne certainement
parce que quand on m'a montré un travail
produit j'étais pas vraiment satisfaite
et je me suis notamment rendu compte
qu'en fait il est capable de produire
des mots mais de là à donner une
implication personnelle notamment nous
qui avons une certaine incarnation quand
on porte un message ça doit faire
référence à ce qu'on pense à ce qu'on a
pu dire avant et ça aujourd'hui
l'intelligence artificielle est pas
encore en dans la version 4 alors je
sais pas c'était la version 4 ou pas
mais j'ai vu des démonstrations de
version 4 avec Raphaël Doan qui est venu
en fait en audition devant la délégation
à la prospective du Sénat et là j'avoue
qu'à la sortie de l'audition je me suis
dit mais en fait demain c'est l'école
blanc qui vont être déclassé et pas les
blouses bleues parce qu'effectivement on
peut demander beaucoup de choses à chpt4
on peut même lui demander de faire du
code informatique avec une limite quand
même c'est qu'il produit à partir de ce
qu'il a mangé et ce qu'il a mangé en
gros à 6 mois d'antériorité donc si on
veut parler de de de de la période
récente les 6 derniers mois ben on peut
c'est une vraie limite donc voilà là
c'est quand on est sur des quand même
sur quelque chose qui qui qui discute de
l'instant présent qui voilà je pense que
demain nous on n pas encore complètement
remplacé par contre il y a certaines
choses qu'on fait et on l'a vu
d'ailleurs avec les analyses
d'amendements déposé au PLF où ça a été
très facile de dénoncer les copier colur
ouais oui effectivement alors tiens je
peux vous pouvez remettre le le plan
large parce que on a choisi en
illustration un une image de robot super
flippante mais on va essayer dans ce
dans ce débat de de montrer qu'il y a il
y a peut-être des craintes mais il y a
aussi des des opportunités avec
l'intelligence artificielle tiens je
vous cite une une anecdote récente un
match organisé entre donc chat GPT fort
dernière version et puis des étudiants
d'un cours d'innovation de la Wharton
School la Wharton School c'est l'une des
plus
prestigieuse école de commerce au monde
hein c'est HC version américaine l'idée
c'était il faut trouver des idées
nouvelles et puis ensuite les faire
tester au marché à des vrais clients
bref vous voyez venir le résultat c'est
que chat GPT a battu à plat de couture
les étudiants donc il y a quand même une
capacité de création d'innovation
d'inventer des idées qui est quand même
assez perturbante est-ce que en quoi
elle est beaucoup plus puissante cette
version que la précédente et est-ce
qu'on peut expliquer pourquoi comment ça
se nourrit une une générative Olivier
lascar alors effectivement il y a
l'intelligence artificielle
ce sont des algorithmes mais ce sont
aussi des bases de données c'est de la
data ce qui fait qu'il y a une émergence
extraordinaire de l'intelligence
artificielle depuis une vingtaine
d'années c'est parce qu'on a cette man
extraordinaire qui est Internet grâce à
internet on a des monceau de données qui
peuvent être partagés et qui viennent
des quatre coins du monde et ces données
certaines d'entre elles sont d'accès
libre et grâce à des milliards de pages
de Wikipédia les développeurs de
l'intelligence artificielle ont pu
travailler aujourd'hui un outil comme
chat GPT là dans la 4e version permet
effectivement de faire une sorte
d'autocomplé c'est-à-dire qu'il agrège
des données à la façon puzzle quoi façon
puzzle comme disait odiar euh en euh
reprenant ses petites briques et en
obtenant des objets qui il y a quelque
chose qui est de l'ordre de la
créativité effectivement mais il faut
pas in même si' ne fait que utiliser des
idées qui ont déjà qui ont été inventé
par hum ouioui il y a toujours la
tendance de l'anthropomorphisme quand on
parle de l'intelligence artificielle on
projette beaucoup sur les capacités de
la machine mais il ne faut pas oublier
que ça n'est jamais que de
l'autocompression et il faut pas tomber
dans un une chose strape gigantesque qui
est que chat GPT et ses outil là ne sont
pas des moteurs de recherche il ne faut
pas leur faire confiance sur le fond on
a tendance à les utiliser comme ça c'est
la grande c'est la grande erreur et euh
c'est l'angle mort il faut pas il faut
pas tomber làdedans il y a ce qu'on
appelle les hallucinations de Lia on y
reviendra évidemment Jean-Gabriel
ganassia il y a quand même dans je
continue là dans ce premier chapitre de
notre débat à essayer d'évaluer les les
ces progrès fulgurants là de de cette IA
générative en l'occurrence chatp for
même si on a beaucoup d'autres formes
par exemple euh le chat gpt3 avait raté
l'examen du barreau pour devenir avocat
ou l'examen pour devenir médecin chat
gpt4 l'a réussi ça et jusqu'où ça va
aller quoi vous voyez il faut il faut
quand même faire la part des légendes
dans tout ça parce que moi j'ai lu des
articles scientifiques sur la réussite
soi-disant réussite de ch gpt4 à
l'examen du barreau et en réalité c'est
une épreuve particulière et ce sont dans
des conditions un peu spécifiques euh
euh ça veut pas du tout dire
queà voilà c'est c'est pas tout à fait
mais c'est beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça je crois qu'il faut
rappeler quand même ce que c'est ce sont
des modèles de langues qui se sont
développés à partir de 2017 dans les
laboratoires de la société Google avec
une notion qui est la notion de
transformer le thé hein c'est le thé de
GPT et c'est le thé d'un autre modèle
qui avait été réalisé par Google
auparavant qui s'appelait berth puis
ensuite avec tout un tas de déclinaisons
dans toutes les langues par exemple en
français il y a deux déclinaisons c'est
caban Bert et
Flobert alors mis à part ça donc
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
l'idée c'est qu'on on on met des réseaux
de neurones et très gros hein qui ont
des milliards des dizaines des centaines
de milliards de Conn HM c'est
vertigineux vous save que notre cerveau
comprend à peu près 80 milliards de
neurones alors ça fait beaucoup plus de
connexion parceque chaque neurone est
connecté à entre 1000 et 10000 autres
neurones mais c'est énorme et donc dans
ces grands modèles qu'est-ce qu'on fait
ben on prend des texte en entrée on
essaie de d'extraire l'esprit de la
langue à l'intérieur du réseau et on
essaie de retrouver le même texte à la
sortie du du réseau et on fait apprendre
et donc là on extrait donc le sens de la
langue ça sert dans beaucoup de
technologies du traitement de la langue
naturelle les résumés de texte ce qu'on
appelle l'extraction d'entités norm
questions réponse et pu dans la
génération de texte et là c'est
exactement ce qu'Olivier lascar vient de
dire on essaie d'anticiper ce que va
être le mot suivant donc ce sont des
perroquets ça répète exactement ce que
l'on dit mais bien sûr ça peut être
complètement invraisemblable alors c'est
ce qui fait la magie parce que on leur a
posé he des des questions par exemple
qu'est-ce que vous pensez des oreillers
en plume de stylo alors il dit ouais les
plumes de stylo
c'est
bien moralité moralité ne l'utilisons
pas comme un moteur de recherche soyons
ultra prudents sur la façon dont utilis
les résultat
lasion aujourd'hui beaucoup de sociétés
essayent de travailler avec l'esprit de
la langue donc sur le modèle de langage
et puis ensuite un petit corpus et on va
confronter les réponses au petit corpus
et à ce moment-là et ben on pourrait
avoir des réponses qui seraient validées
parce queelles trouveront à intérieur et
ça c'est très utile dans pour la
fonction publique en particulier
sur sens public parce que on pourrait
utiliser ça comme interface avec les
citoyens pour poser un certain nombre de
questions éventuellement dans des
domaines où la législation est de plus
en plus complexe essayer de retrouver la
législation et cetera donc est-ce que ça
veut dire j'ouvre une petite parenthèse
que les les les Chabot là auquel on est
souvent confronté quand on arrive sur un
nouveau site voilà conversationnel il
eux ils deviennent de plus en plus
intelligents ou en tout cas une capacité
de plus en plus important à répon à
répondre à des questions complexes on
peut dire ça qu'est-ce qu' appelle
intelligence pour ça que j'ai mis leot
de Cé un peu délicat mais en tout cas
bien sûr on peut avoir une réponse alors
d'abord les phrases sont à peu près
correctement formées et et en tout cas
nous en tant qu'enseignant on est un peu
bloffé parce que c'est mieux formé que
beaucoup de nos
étudi après le sens ça varie ça flotte
un peu et puis ce sont tous les lieux
comm qu'on peut imaginer c'est un style
très platès très ennuyeux donc c'est
vraiment ce qu'il ne faut pas faire he
pour les pour les étudiants alors je je
on élargit on élargit sur le le le pas
seulement là je sors de chat GPT
l'intelligence artificielle en en
général parce que la grande question
c'est peut-être un peu une tarte à la
crème est-ce qu'il faut en avoir peur
est-ce qu'ell peurvent prendre le
pouvoir faç son Terminator on a tous le
le le le film en tête bon je vous
propose un témoignage c'est pas
n'importe qui c'est quand même l'un des
pèes fondateurs de Lia il s'appelle
Yoshua benio il est professeur il est
québécois voilà ce qu' nous dit et si
leurs objectifs ne correspondent pas à
ce que nous on veut justement les
questions éthiques qu'est-ce qui est bon
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui est
qu'est-ce qui est adéquat qu'est-ce
qu'est-ce qu'on désire qu'est-ce qu'on a
comme valeur euh ces systèmes là
pourraient prendre des décisions qui
nous nuisent et même mettre en danger
l'espèce humaine Christine Lavarde c'est
un débat presque anthropologique que que
devient l'espèce humaine est-ce que on
est à cette croisée des chemins d'après
vous ou est-ce que on ex ère quand on se
pose cette question bah la semaine
dernière un colloque avait lieu au Sénat
justement sur l'intelligence
artificielle et moi j'ai animé une table
ronde sur l'intelligence artificielle
demain dans trois secteurs très
différents la santé l'éducation et la
défense ou effectivement quand on se
pose la question de la défense on est
très vite confronté à cette question de
jusqu'où peut-on aller est-ce qu'on
pourra parce que là on peut être face à
des armes létales de de de massif parce
que un robot tueur on a même plus le
problème d'envoyer quelqu'un qui va se
faire tuer on n plus que face à de la
matière qui va tuer des êtres humains
donc c'est plus du tout quand il y a un
attentat la personne qui va se faire
exploser à un moment quand même elle se
dit qu'elle va mourir pour la cause là
quand on envoie un robot qu'en plus on
est très loin parce qu'on peut les
commander à distance ça change quand
même aussi la manière de de de de de
faire la guerre et donc un débat
actuellement sur l'utilisation de
l'intelligence artificielle par Israël
dans la guerre d'Israël à Hamas bah et
c'est surtout par exemple les États-Unis
et et la Chine au moment du du sommet
Chine États-Unis on ont pas convergé sur
grand-chose mais ils ont convergé sur un
point c'est de se dire il faut que nos
experts en intelligence artificielle
discutent ensemble pour savoir jusqu'où
on va aller si jamais devient un conflit
a lieu et savoir comment on utilisera
l'IA donc votre avis là-dessus Olivier
lascar je vous redne la parole juste
après est-ce que on peut jeends je parle
de Terminator quoi c'est inversion des
rôles les les humains transformés en
esclaves des robots alors c'est je pense
que c'est tout à fait légitime de se
poser la question et c'est pertinent et
effectivement ce qui est d' trop c'est
que les plus grands spécialistes parmi
les plus grands spécialistes certains se
la posent il y a eu le psychodrame il y
a quelques semaines autour de openi oui
avec le président Sam Altman viré puis
réintégré voilà derrière ce pas de deux
ou il y avait un débat sur la
destination de l'intelligence
artificielle et il y avait une position
qui était défendue par Altman qui est
celle de Lia tousazimut à marche forcée
on se pose pas trop de questions et
derrière dans le conseil de surveillance
il y a une personnalité qui est Ilas
suever un ingénieur d'origine
ukrainienne je crois qui est vraiment un
petit génie de
l'informatique qui qui est là dès le
début d'openi et qui lui était sur une
position et sur une position beaucoup
plus comment dirais-je prudente c'est
l'heure de freiner c'est l'heure de
freiner c'est l'heure de se poser des
questions à l'intérieur d'Open il
travaille sur la question de
l'alignement des intelligences
artificielles qui est en gros se donner
les moyens de toujours assujettir
l'intelligence artifici artificielle au
créateur humain qui est derrière lui
c'est le spectre de frankinstein on
ninente rien mais il est toujours là il
est toujours pertinent et donc le fait
que des acteurs aussi pointu se pose la
question c'est quand même une raison de
légitimer le débat évidemment il y a
aussi des voix il y a yen Lequin en
France qui est le patron de
l'intelligence artificielle chez MTA qui
est plutôt du genre à dire écoutez on se
calme on boit une tisane ouis hein on se
tranquillise sur la question mais voilà
il y en a d'autres évidemment quand
c'est musk qui pose cette question comme
il a ce côté olibrius on a plutôt
tendance à éliminer à beauté en touche
oui et puis on le soupçonne de dire ça
parce qu'il est un peu en retard par
rapport à ses concurrents aussi c'est
une possibilité Jean-Gabriel ganasscia
votre avis là-dessus sur ce débat je
disais anthropologique mon avis il est
double d'abord sur la question de la
défense il faut bien distinguer les
armes à distance comme drones h et puis
l'utilisation d'intelligence
artificielle pour fabriquer des armes
autonomes or selon moi le concept
d'armes autonome n'existe pas d'ailleurs
les j'ai fait mon service militaire il y
a très longtemps la seule chose dont je
me souviens c'est que les militaires
veulent qu'on leur obéisse et donc il
voudrait avoir des systèmes d'armes
qu'il maîtrisent complètement or une
arme autonome c'est une arme qui vous
échappe et les militaires et qui j'ai
discuté ne souhaite pas d'armes
autonomees et d'ailleurs ils ont
introduit un concept voyez système
d'armes létal
et puis système d' l intégrant de
l'autonomie et c'est de ça don il est
question aujourd'hui quand on parle
d'israël c'est de ça c'est de ça on par
vous laiss jeis vous laisser sur le
deuxème argument
mais j'en profite parce que je pose une
question volontairement un peu
provocatrice peut y avoir des apprentis
sorciers qui décident de les créer ces
armes ces armes autonomes comment on les
maîtriseprs oui mais ce qui est
important c'est de bien comprendre que
ces armes ont des cibles ces cibles ont
été conçu par des hommes donc c'est
autonome au sens tech teologique mais
pas au sens philosophique pas autonome
au sens elles
pourontin alors il se peut que on est
mal conçu c'està-dire qu'on est donné
une cible qui soit problématique qui a
des
effets adverses enfin les effets
collatéraux tout à fait
décevant ça c'est sur la défense je
crois qu'il y a beaucoup de malentendus
là-dessus de même une voiture autonome
elle est pas autonome au sens
philosophique hein parce que ce serait
très désagréable qu'elle déciderit là
vous voulez qu'elle vous obéisse premier
point le deuxème point c'est ce débat
qui existe et et Benjo bon qui est très
connu hein parce qu'il est à l'origine
avec Yan Lequin et et jeintton de
l'apprentissage profond et puis de ce
qu'on appelle les Gan les réseaux
adversari génératifs essae de de nous
effrayer mais il est pas le seul ça fait
longtemps ça fait des années hein depuis
2016 2017 il y a des lettres qui sont
récurrentes et je crois que ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est que ce sont
ce qu'on appelle des pompiers Pyroman
c'estd que ce sont ceux qui font
l'intelligence artificielle qui vous
explique qu'elle est dangereuse et on
devrait se demander mais pourquoi elle
est dangereuse et qu'est-ce qui est
dangereux or je crois que le risque
c'est d'agiter les peurs d'agiter les
chiffons rouges parce qu'on sait que
dans la population he ça nous effraie
tous et quand on voit ça et ben on ne
voit pas la réalité et donc il y a
effectivement des dangers liés au
développement de l'intelligence
artificielle mais ils ne sont pas ceux
d'avoir une machine autonome ils sont
ceux d'avoir une transformation de la
société c'est un danger politique
c'estàdire que on a des nouveaux acteurs
qui intervienent qui ont un pouvoir
considérable et qui transformment la
société et c'est je crois surtout dans
une émission comme la vôtre de cela dont
il faut parler c'est pas simplement de
ces fables qui sont très anciennes parce
qu'on rejoint les fables de pigmalion
les fables du golem les fables des
robots et cetera mais la réalité elle
est autre est-ce que c'est pas quand
même je reviens vers vous Christin sur
sur le même ce que pe ce que peuvent
devenir nos sociétés est-ce qu'on on
pourrait aller vers une société du
loisir ou des loisirs pour les humains
avec les robots qui qui travaillent quoi
vous voyez ce que je veux dire mais
alors justement la délégation la
prospective du Sénat là vient de lancer
un cycle qui sera le travail de l'année
2024 autour de intelligence artificielle
et services publics donc dans un format
un peu nouveau puisque jusqu'à présent
la délégation travaillait pas comme ça
en choisissant des thèmes et sur ces
thèmes par exemple on va avoir un thème
sur ila et fiscalité et donc à
l'inérieur de cette envelop de ce de
cette chapitre on va s'intéresser savoir
j est-ce que liya doit aller vers la
fraude est-ce que doit aller vers
améliorer le recours justement au
dispositif enfin on va choisir un angle
donc ça c'est les les rapporteurs qui
vont choisir on va s'intéresser par
exemple à la question de Ia et
environnement et parce qu'on voit que
l'environnement dans la maîtrise du Zéro
artificialisation enfin voilà ça peut
aussi apporter des outils on va
s'intéresser bien évidemment à ia et
culture Ia et
santé mais dans quel esprit pour se
poser la question de l'évolution des
métiers de ceux qui vont muter de ceux
qui vont disparaître de ceux qui vont
apparaître pour se poser la question et
éclairer en fait puisque c'est ça la
vocation de la délégation à la
prospective c'est éclairer le le
politique sur le monde dans lequel on
pourrait vivre à horizon alors 2050 mais
peut-être même plus près hein et donc en
est en élaborant des scénarios qui sont
des scénarios de prospective donc
certains se diront peut-être mais c'est
complètement futuriste et d'autres se
diront en fait non c'est ça qu'on va
vivre et donc il faut s'y préparer et
donc indirectement par exemple Ia et
santé on voit bien on le sait
aujourd'hui l'intelligence artificielle
est capable de prédire aussi bien euh
qu'un médecin en regardant euh des
radios parce que à force de lire des
radios et d'avoir le diagnostic il est
capable en rapprochant de se dire la
personne a ça et donc la question c'est
est-ce que demain on aura plus que des
intelligences artificielles qui lisent
des radios ou est-ce qu'on va garder
autant de médecins h et qui auront en
fait on sera aidé de l'intelligence
artificielle pour avoir par exemple la
double lecture gérée par l'intelligence
artificielle et redonner du temps
médical du temps humain pour justement
ce qui est le dialogue la communication
sur la gestion de la maladie et ça c'est
des c'est des vraies questions parce
qu'on pourra avoir une approche à se
dire bon bah c'est super j'ai 3000
milliards de dettes bon qu'est-ce que je
vaux faire je manque de médecin très
simple et ben je mets un ordinateur et
puis ça va résoudre mes problèmes et
c'est pas forcément le monde donc nous
en tant humain on a envie de vivre
dedans ce que l'on peut déjà faire avec
l'intelligence artificielle notamment en
matière de de d'image et de son parmi
les les promesses sympathiques en tout
cas moi je les trouve sympathique la
possibilité de dialoguer avec des génies
disparus c'est ce qu'a testé le le
coprésident du Conseil national du
numérique Gill Babinet il était
d'ailleurs auditionné au Sénat on
l'écoute Académie a fait un truc que
j'ai expérimenté qui est vraiment
remarquable vous pouvez aller sur leur
site je pense que c'est en ligne mais
vous avez des des des des conversations
avec des grands personnages de
l'histoire donc vous pouvez parler avec
Marie curry enfin tous ceux qui ont
beaucoup écrit parce qu'évidemment pour
qu'on alimente le modèle il faut que ils
a beaucoup écrit donc on peut même
parler avec des gens qui sont des quasi
qu'on a sûr qu'ils a vraiment existé en
tant que tel comme Shakespeare mais donc
on a une représentation imagée de
Shakespeare mais mais néanmoins comme il
a beaucoup écrit on peut avoir une
conversation avec Shakespeare et et donc
c'est assez bluffant parce que vous
pouvez mettre un enfant de 5 ans devant
Einstein comme vous pouvez mettre un
scientifique de de qui fait de
l'astrophysique de très très haut niveau
à cette écar et
donc tout cela est extrêmement
prometteur Olivier lascar ce que
l'intelligence artificielle permet de
faire avec l'image et le son il y a
notamment je crois c'est M journée c'est
ça est-ce que c'est pas là ce qui est le
plus bluffant aujourd'hui ah c'est
extraordinaire moi je je évidemment je
suis comme tout le monde je m'amuse là
depuis enfin je m'amuse j'expérimente
parce que je sais bien que ça a une
répercussion sur mon travail et ça va
l'avoir donc il faut connaître faut
savoir quelles sont les armes qui sont
là pour pouvoir réagir et c'est
absolument
vertigineux on peut tout faire alors moi
ce que je m'amusais ces derniers temps
c'est je rentrais des phrases de roman
vous savez la phrase de Flobert
vous citiez Flobert euh c'était à Mégara
faubourg de Carthage dans les jardins
d'Amilcar la phrase de Salambo qui ouvre
Salambo vous lui renter ça en 10
secondes il vous répond c'est
extrêmement stimulant comme projet que
d'illustrer cette
phrase 3 secondes plus tard elle sort il
prend le on DIN point de vue de la
gravure ancienne on a l'impression dans
un vieux livre pas un bécherelle mais
enfin à la même époque équivalent et il
y Ava pas beaucoup de dessins dans dans
les bécherell de ma jeunesse ce que jeux
direo on a suffisamment transpiré dessus
pour extraordinaire et et et et ces
capacités sont alors le Gill baminet
s'amuse à parler avec einin Einstein moi
je rentre les éditau de sciené à venir
je dis refais-lemoi dans le style Trump
alors dit vous connaissez cette
extraordinaire matière noire qui fait
des formidables donc c'est absolument
vertigineux et ça pose évidemment la
question de des des des des métiers qui
vont être impactés mais récemment je
parlais avec ingénieur ingénieur de
cette question pour un papier il me
disait euh est-ce que les ingénieurs
vont être remplacés les ingénieurs vont
être remplacés par les ingénieurs qui
maîtrisent l'intelligence artificielle
ça c'est certainou la mutation des
métiers et notamment la question des
médias on va en parler tout de suite
avec Steve jour Jourdain les les médias
en première ligne en quelque sorte
rebonsoir Steve parlez-nous de ce
bouleversement des pratiques là pour nos
métiers je vais vous montrer ça en image
he on va voir ce dernier exemple en date
avec ce JT entièrement conçu par
l'intelligence artificielle je suis viré
ça 10 secondes de chronique je suis viré
on est aux États-Unis donc pour
l'instant vous êtes pas pas concerné on
est aux États-Unis il n a ni
présentateur ni chroniqueur ni reporter
de terrain ou plutôt si il y a tout ça
mais ils sont entièrement fake
entièrement créés par l'intelligence
artificielle
[Musique]
regardez
voilà ça c'est un teaser la chaîne va
être lancée officiellement au mois de
février diffusion 24h/ 24 7 jours sur 7
L'objectif de Channel 1 c'est de
produire des flux d'information
personnalisé c'est important Thas c'est
un peu comme l'appli TikTok je sais pas
si vous avez l'appli TikTok votre télé
va et bien apprendre de vos goûts de vos
habitudes de vos préférence et grâce à
un algorithme elle sera en mesure de
vous proposer un contenu qui retiendra
plus facilement votre attention bref le
20h de TF1 diffusé à tout le monde à la
même heure avec un même contenu je suis
désolé de vous le dire Thomas bah c'est
terminé bon ça fait un moment que je
quité moi aussi le VUR de de TF1 si vous
voulez ce teaser qui a suscité
évidemment beaucoup de réactions aux
États-Unis oui a raison ces fake
journalistes peuvent être de formidables
véhicules de fake news ils ne sont pas
en mesure évidemment de vérifier
eux-mêmes l'information qu'il
transmettent en France on se souvient
peut-être de ces photos Thomas qui avait
circulé sur les réseaux sociaux pendant
la réforme des des retraites Emmanuel
Macron voilà pour chasser par des
manifestants il y avait aussi Emmanuel
Macron qui manifestait contre sa propre
réforme les journalistes avaient assez
facilement débunker vérifier ces fake
news mais parfois et bien ce sont des
journalistes eux-mêmes qui utilisent
l'intelligence artificielle cette une on
va la voir du Journal du Dimanche
magazine qui a été publié au mois de mai
Michel Welbeck qui gambade dans les
champs l'idée c'était de questionner le
personnage et l'authenticité de de
l'écrivain ouis effectivement belle
image mais créée totalement par une
intelligence artificielle on on l'a bien
compris et ce qui est de plus en plus
questionné aussi STEVE c'est
l'authenticité des publications des
journalistes oui comment être sûr qu'un
article soit écrit par un vrai jour
journalist c'est de plus en plus
difficile des médias ont lancé pour
répondre à ce problème ont lancé des
chartes éthiques de l'intelligence
artificielle l'objectif et bien c'est
évidemment de de maintenir le lien de
confiance avec la population avec les
citoyens reporter sans frontière a par
exemple présenté le mois dernier une
charte internationale de liia dans les
médias on va voir par il y a eu 10
points qui ont été publiés parmi ces 10
points il y a notamment cette idée que
le jugement humain doit rester centrale
dans les décisions éditoriales ou encore
que les médias doivent aider la société
à discerner à avec confiance les
contenus authentiques et synthéti cette
chronique que vous venez d'entendre je
vous assure elle est originale elle est
authentique c'est un peu moins le cas de
la vidéo vous allez voir c'est une bonne
annonce d'une excellente émission sur
public SC
regard
iminac
public je parle pas vous turc et
l'espagnol voilà ça a pris quelques quoi
secondes minutes pour utiliser à partir
d'une d'une vraie
bandeannonce de l'envoil le flu et c'est
revenu en version dans toutes les
langues que que l'on veut enfin je
remarque quand même que vous avez choisi
pour illustrer la chronique votre propre
émission ce qui est totalement égotique
et ça c'est parfaitement ça c'est
parfaitement
humain une intelligence artificielle
l'aurait pas fait merci beaucoup Steve
pour pour cette explication qui était
effectivement assez édifiante Jean
Gabriel Gal qu'on vient de voir quand
même la la la vidéo donc vidéo
français traduite en enfin là il y a un
métier qui disparaît traducteur d'un
côté il y a des métiers qui DISP a qui
vont se créer il y a de nouveau métiers
qui se
créent ce sont pas tant les traductions
qui disparaissent il y aura de plus en
plus de traducteurs je pense qu'il y
aura de plus en plus de choses à
traduire mais il y aura des tâches une
partie de la tâche pardon je comprends
pas votre argument parce là en
l'occurrence il y a pas eu besoin d'un
traducteur c'est de l'interprétation
mais je suis pas sûr qu'on interprète
tout enfin je je suis pas aussi effrayé
que ça je pense que les métiers évoluent
parce que il y a un certain nombre de
tâches qui se font automatiquement euh
par exemple je suis certain qu'il y aura
toujours des illustrateurs simplement
bien sûr une grande partie des
illustrations pourront être faites
automatiquement donc effectivement
l'évolution du travail c'est une
question difficile et puis une étude
rétrospective montre que il y a moins de
chômage aujourd'hui en France qu'il y en
avait il y a il y a 20 ou 30 ans or il y
a plus d'automatisme les pays où il y a
le plus de robots sont les pays où euh
euh il y a le moins de chômage donc vous
voyez la corrélation entre
l'automatisation et le chômage est pas
aussi simple que ça alors c'est c'est
une vieille crainte hein et d'ailleurs
le terme robot c'est qui vient d'une
pièce de théâtre hein dans laquelle
justement euh euh les travailleurs
artificiels euh gagnaient en dignité par
leur travail ce que les hommes perdaient
en dignité ils prenaient le pouvoir mais
ça c'est c'est un vieux fantasme la
réalité est beaucoup plus complexe que
cela il y a beaucoup plus de le risque
c'est plutôt que I pardon de interrompe
là là on commence la période de mutation
donc ça veut dire non mais sur l'école
blanc sur sur sur les métiers de
création de la connaissit quand
mêmets dis tout à l'heure la
robotisation les
ouvri pas du tout cette inquiétude là je
pense que ce qui va se passer plutôt
c'est que il y aura de plus en plus de
il faut se former à ces nouveaux til et
et d'autre part par exemple vous en tant
que journaliste est-ce que vous risquez
moi je pense que c'est l'inverse je
pense que c'est votre chance aujourd'hui
parce que ce sera à vous de de vérifier
c'est ça l'éthique de
journaliste j'espère j'espère mais bon
avec des citoyens qui sont enfermés dans
leur bule cognitive et et qui ne croient
que ce que leur proch le en permettre je
voulais ajouter un point parce que
rapidement parce qu' faut ouis alors on
craint avec cela que il y ait des
nouvelles fausses mais je pense que le
grand der n'est pas là le grand anger
c'est ce que vous venez de dire c'est
que les citoyens sont enfermés dans une
bulle et que chacun a sa propre
information c'est le ciblage ça utilise
de l'intelligence artificielle et que ça
conduise à une société de plus en plus
fragmentée c'est que l'espace public
disparaisse c'est ça je pense l'enjeu
majeur pour le futur Olivier lascar le
le le métier de journaliste c'est
d'aller sur le terrain d'aller
rencontrer des des sources des humains
de comprendre ce qu'ils nous disent et
de le rendre intelligible pour pour pour
les autres on est on est bien d'accord
définition un peu basique mais c'est ça
ça un robot pourra pas le faire non il
pourra pas le faire il pourra aider
grandement le journaliste à le faire
parce que quand on va sur le terrain et
qu'on interview PierrePaul et Jacques on
rentre à la rédaction avec des monceaux
de notes ouais les systèmes
d'automatisation permettent de faciliter
la conversion de la note sur un papier
gribouillé en de la prise de note sur un
traitement de texte informatique à faire
un premier jus la peur de la page
blanche h elle est abolie avec des
systèmes comme cela premier un une
première synthèse en quelque s une
première un premier g une première
synthèse qui ne sera pas l'article
définitif c'est un l'URE que de
considérer que la machine va pouvoir en
appuyant sur un bouton faire un papier
pour raconter pour expliquer pourquoi le
ciel est bleu en revanche elle pourra
agréger les données qui seront fournies
par le journaliste parce qu'encore une
fois c'est pas un moteur de cherche de
recherche l'information qui est fournie
par ces outilsl n'est pas fiable en
revanche elle sait faire le paquet
cadeau avec le ruban qui va autour il y
a eu un cas de figure édifiant qui a été
mis au jour par la rédaction de newsgard
à propos du soi-disant psychiatre de
netanahou il y avait une actu qui est
allée jusqu'à la télé iranienne
expliquant que le psychiatre de
netanahou s'était suicidé parce que il
était accablé d'avoir comme patient
netaniaahou cette actu on s'est rendu
compte news guardard s'est rendu compte
qu'elle venait d'un site parodique
pakistanais qui avait fait cette
histoire pour rigoler humour noir il a
pas d'humour histoire a été reprise par
par lia parce queelle a alimenté les
instruments les moteurs de info comme
une autre et aujourd'hui quand on teste
sur Chat GPT puisque chat GPT est adossé
au système Bing de Microsoft qui est euh
Moché yatb je crois que c'est le nom
qu'il lui ont donné et ben elle vous
explique que c'est le psychat netanaho
alors que ce typelà n'a jamais existéou
donc en tant que producteur c'est pas
tellement producteur de fake news c'est
une forme de blanchiment de la fake news
puisque ça va euh enregistrer toutes les
occurrences qui sont faites à son sujet
alors on se pose la question de de de la
maîtrise comment maîtriser garder la
main sur l'intelligence artificielle
c'est une question qu'on se pose ici en
Europe mais un peu partout dans le monde
on va en parler avec vous Tam tranu mais
d'abord C cet accord qui a été trouvé au
niveau de l'Union européenne première la
première à le faire c'était la semaine
dernière réguler les usages de de l'IA
évidemment satisfaction du commissaire
européen au Marché intérieur tiri on
l'écoute l'accord que nous avons conclu
aujourd'hui est un accord complet il
s'agit vraiment de quelque chose qui est
bien plus je crois qu'un livre de règles
il s'agit d'une rampe de lancement pour
les start-up européennes et les
chercheurs afin qu'il mèneent la course
mondiale vers ce que veulent nos
citoyens une intelligence artificielle
digne de confiance on l'a entendu Tam
thieron que des compliments à faire
c'est pas vraiment le cas d'Emmanuel
Macron voilà Thierry Breton qui même
qualifié cet accord d'historique hein le
mot qu'elle voit en poupe cette semaine
entre l'accord trouvé par la COP 28 et
celui donc de ce règlement européen en
gros ça veut dire que quand vous avez
enfermé pendant plusieurs jours de très
nombreuses parties avec des avis
radicalement différents bien vous
poussez un ouf de soulagement lorsque
vous voyez la fumée blanche qui sort de
la salle ça arrivera peut-être lors de
la commission mixte paritaire mardi
prochain au bout de 38 he de négociation
en tout cas Thierry Breton qui est en
plus l'un des architectes de ce texte
était donc hyper positif enthousiasme
douché dès le lendemain par Emmanuel
Macron qui déclare lui que ce n'est pas
une bonne idée et que ce règlement
européen fait que on est le premier
endroit au monde où on va beaucoup plus
réguler que les autres et d'ailleurs
c'est pas la première fois que le chef
de l'État est dans cet état d'esprit et
et dit et craint que l'Europe soit à la
traain on va l'écouter hein d'ailleurs
lors du salon vivatex c'était au mois de
juin dernier les États-Unis d'Amérique
de très loin et même la Chine qui est
quand même aujourd'hui un peu derrière
les les Américains mais les deux grands
leaders vont beaucoup plus vite que nous
Français et que nous Européens donc pour
moi la priorité c'est vraiment de faire
du en même temps pour le coup c'estàdire
qu'il faut faire en même temps de
l'accélération pour la recherche
l'innovation et la création d'un
écosystème très puissant et participer à
une régulation mais dont le périmètre
doit être le plus large possible alors
ce qui nous intéresse dans cette
séquence c'est d'abord bien sûr le
discours Emmanuel Macron a beau parler
de en même temps on sent qu'il veut
davantage insister sur la favorisation
de l'innovation que sur la régulation
mais c'est surtout avec qui il est dans
cette séquence et oui l'image est
intéressante aussi on voit dessus il y a
un trentenaire en chemise blanche à côté
du président de la République ce
trentenaire c'est l'homme dont tout le
monde parle cette semaine Arthur mench
le PDG de Mistral ai Mistral ai c'est la
start-up française de l'intelligence
artificiel oui elle a 7 mois une
vingtaine de personnes mais elle a levé
105 millions d'euros une première fois
puis 385 millions lundi dernier à les
valorisé à 2 milliards d'euros ses
créateurs à lit l'excellence académique
française Polytechnique normal sup et
l'expérience chez les géants américains
que sont Google et meta et last but not
least on parle anglais parce qu'on parle
de start-up elle bénéficie d'un soutien
très fort du gouvernement l'ancien
secrétaire d'État au numérique Cédric ha
compte parmi ses conseillers
cofondateurs tout en étant membre du
Comité interministérial sur l'IA
générative qui a été créé au mois de
septembre par Elizabeth born de quoi
assurer le relais de ces messages au
plus haut notamment ces grandes
inquiétudes à l'égard du nouveau
règlement européen l'exécutif français
serait-il tenté de céder lobbying de
cette start-up c'est ce qu'a dit Thierry
Breton hein il a parlé de ce lobbying il
a dit attention cette licorne française
œuvre pour ses intérêts particuliers et
non pour l'intérêt général alors
évidemment le gouvernement il n'a qu'une
crainte he que trop de régulation tue
cette licorne dans l'œuf ou lui fasse
quitter l'hexagone on peut tempérer un
petit peu les craintes il faut quand
même rappeler que encadrer l'ya ce n'est
pas qu'une lub européenne il y a eu le
premier Sommet mondial sur les risques
de Lia au mois de novembre il y a Joe
Biden qui a commencé à encadrer lia aux
États-Unis même le pape aujourd'hui a
appelé à règlement l'elligence artifici
alors est-ce que les startup françaises
européennes crient avant d'avoir mal ou
est-ce que leurs craintes sont fondées
bon l'avenir le dira avec une touche
d'espoir quand même pour conclure Thomas
l'Europe compte aujourd'hui plus de
talents hautement qualifiés sur l'IA que
les États-Unis moralité et bien si le
règlement européen tue quelques
entreprises nous avons normalement
suffisamment de cerveau pour en créer de
nouvelles oui on va en débattre de ça
peut-être d'abord un avis général
Christine lavard sur cette loi
européenne sur l'A elle était nécessaire
il faut il faut réglementer c'est
peut-être déjà un peu tard alors je
pense qu'elle est nécessaire pour donner
confiance aux citoyens h moi je l'ai vu
pour un autre travail que j'ai mené à la
délégation à la prospective qui était à
la sortie de la crise du covid et on
avait travaillé sur l'usage des outils
numériques pour dans la gestion de crise
et comment si on avait mieux utilisé
numérique on aurait peut-être pas eu
besoin d'avoir son petit formulaire
papier qui fallait remplir à chaque fois
qu'on voulait sortir en en bas de chez
soi et ça a donné un senti ent de rejet
très très fort enfin le rapport a
vraiment été manipulé instrumentalisé
par certains pour dire mais stop c'est
la fin de la liberté c'est le Crédit
Social à la chinoise ils sont
complètement fous au Sénat et parce que
il y a toujours eu en fait une craintte
du citoyen mais c'est très ancien ça
date pas que des années 2000 même quand
on était dans les fiches papiers c'était
déjà ça la surveillance de tous
exactement et donc en fait on a le
sentiment que quand l'intelligence
artificielle hier est utilisée par le
secteur public par la puissance publique
tout de suite c'est c'est non euh alors
même que les premiers qui criaient ça
euh étaient en train de nous traîner
dans la Bou sur les réseaux sociaux donc
sur les réseaux sociaux finalement ils
exposent certainement beaucoup plus leur
vie que ce qu'ils n'auraient pu le faire
un outil public qui leur aurait permis
justement de pouvoir circuler donc il
faut arriver si on n'a pas de cadre si
on ne montre pas que la puissance
publique quand même s'intéresse au aux
dérives euh plus personne n'a confiance
je pense dans le système ouais et avec
effectivement cette cette question
l'équilibre entre euh du du contrôle
mais qui soit pas trop strict pour
pouvoir laisser des entreprises
européennes grandir Olivier lascar il
faut effectivement vous l'avez dit Tam
mral c'est valorisation plus de 2
milliards de dollars ENF ça ça reste un
liliip puien face au géants américain il
faut savoir de quoi on parle et puis les
là-bas les les couteaux sont tirés hein
du côté des gsfemes je ve dire il faut
se rendre compte de la de la fureur que
ça a déclenché l'avènement de chchad GPT
en novembre 2022 là
ils sont à qui sortira le plus vite sa
propre formule parce que c'est un combat
à mort qui se qui s'est engagé et donc
il dépense énormément d'argent pour le
faire ben la la la les les sommes que
Microsoft a a loué en fait en équipement
quoi en serveur informatique qui
permettent à openi de fonctionner c'est
de l'ordre de 10 milliards de dollars
donc c'est c'est phénoménal donc
effectivement on a d'un côté les
États-Unis qui galopent mais qui
galopent presque comme un poulet sans
tête on sait pas où est-ce que ça va
aller et de l'autre qu'on l'Europe
championne de la législation elle est
nécessaire je pense cette législation
mais effectivement elle a deux écueils
le premier c'est que les entreprises ne
puissent pas se servir des outils à
disposition par exemple le Gini la
solution d'intelligence artificielle de
Google elle est pas ouverte en Europe
parce que c'est trop compliqué et puis
il faudrait pas non plus que les
systèmes d'intelligence artificielle ne
soient pas développés en Europe parce
que ça voudrait dire qu'elles soit
qu'elles existeraient toutes selon un
biais anglo-saxon aujourd'hui si sur mid
journée vous demandez de faire une rue
typique de Paris ben vous allez en
prendre plein les yeux he parce que
question marinière et tous les clichés
de la France version US donc il faut
aussi qu'il y ait
des voilà exaement Europ un mot de
conclusion c'est la dernière minute de
l'émission sur ce sur ce thème leô thme
oui loi certainement nécessaire la
régulation mais enfin la loi il suffit
de la lire je veux dire S et quelques
pages avec des absurdités complètes
commcer par exemple on vous classe les
niveaux de risque le premier niveau de
risque ce sont les techniques
subliminales or les techniques
subliminales c'est une fraude
c'est-à-dire dans les années 50 un
publiciste américain James far a
expliqué que quand on on mettait des
messages à l'intérieur d'un film toutes
les 25e de secondes ça parvenait pas à
la conscience et ça et ça permettait de
de changer de convaincre les gens or on
on sait il a avoué parce que des
psychologues ont essay de le refaire ça
n'existe pas donc c'est le problème
c'est que c'est une régulation qui est
fondée sur des fant
il y a énormément de choses absurdes à
l'intérieur de cette régulation et
d'autre part vous êtes d'accord sur le
principe attz sur le principe d'une
régulation mais pas sur une régulation
fondée sur le risque parce que le risque
le danger c'est que on ne regarde que
dans le rétroviseur de l'histoire le
problème avec la technologie c'est
qu'elle nous surprend le meilleur
exemple c'est que chaque GPT vous vous
souvenez personne l'avait vu venir enfin
personne un petit peu moi mais c'est une
autre histoire mais parce que je suis
dans je suis dans donc bien sûr c'est
simpleement que cette régulation pose
tout un tas de de problèmes dans sa
rédaction elle est orientée sur le passé
or si on veut être attentif regarder ce
qui est en train d'advenir mais c'est
vrai qu'il faut je crois rassurer les
citoyens il faut expliquer mais cette
régulation elle fait plus peur qu'elle
l'explique justement elle invente des
fantasmes qui correspond à rien du tout
merci beaucoup merci à tous il y encore
plein plein plein de de de thématiques à
aborder notamment mais on fera peut-être
un débat là-dessus pendant la la
campagne américaine quand elle montra en
puissance la la capacité de créer des
des fausses déclarations d'hommes
politiques avec mjournée c'est très très
facile aujourd'hui et ça a déjà été
utilisé dans certaines campagnes
électorales en Europe merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat Olivier
lascar votre livre enquête sur Elon Musk
l'homme qui défie la science est aux
éditions
alisiiocience merci encore je vous dis à
lundi pour un nouveau numéro de sens
public et puis notterz que demaininvité
de la matinale c'est Henry gu l'ancien
commissaire général au PL et ancien
conseiller spécial de Nicolas Sarkozi à
l'Élysée belle
soirée
[Musique]